the channel 8 phone bank answering your
questions today about medicare
enrollment so as we're speaking right
now call the phone number on your screen
and even after we're done here these
folks will be here to answer your
questions i'm joined right now by scott
hanson who is the nevada sales director
of unitedhealthcare thanks for being
here scott thanks kendall why is this
such an important period for people that
want to enroll or singers who are
already enrolled in medicare yeah this
time of year is important because we
want to ensure that
seniors are choosing the medicare plan
that best fits their needs and really
what it's all about this time of year is
it may be the only time of year when
they can readdress the current coverage
that they have add or change their plan
for the coming season this is really
important because if they choose not to
enroll by december 7th they're probably
going to be locked in to their coming
plan for all of 2022 we want to make
sure that they have a plan that best
fits their needs and their budget yeah
and that can be a complicated process
there are a lot of things to consider so
what advice would you give to people
when it comes to finding that right plan
we understand that this can be
complicated but it doesn't have to be
that's part of the reason why we have
our team here today ready to answer
questions ready to find a plan that best
fits their needs there's really three
things that i would recommend that
people think about is they're choosing
their new plan to prepare
one is check the current coverage make
sure it's still good fit for them number
two
make sure that it's a good fit for their
budget because people's needs change
over time and number three make sure
that all their drugs are covered under
their current plan or a new plan and
there are some resources you can tell
people about that will help them through
this whole thing there are and again
that's why our team is here to make sure
that we can answer those questions and
there's a couple online resources as
well i want to make sure that i get this
right the first one is
uhcmedicarehealthplans.com
another great great one is get to know
medicare.com all right scott hanson
thank you so much call the number on
your screen to get your questions
answered they're going to be here
throughout the evening
and the phone number once again is 702
702-650-1101 they'll be answering calls
until 7 o'clock tonight